(mellow indie music)
(applause)
- What's up BuzzFeed?
Oh yeah, VIP tables.
Whose LOL do you have to OMG
to get a seat up in the VIP section?
Uncommonly known as the splash zone.
If you're wondering,
I'm a squirter myself,
so the rumors are true.
I've got a restaurant idea, guys,
for a Lord Of The Rings themed
restaurant called Mordor,
and when you come to this restaurant
the waiters greet you by saying,
welcome to Mordor, may I take your ordor?
(laughter)
I'm in kind of a rough space, man,
kind of a weird mood, my
grandpa died recently.
Yeah, and he was a
really philosophical guy,
and I was actually in the
room with him when he died,
and I'll never forget his last words.
He said, the black nurse
drank my orange juice.
(laughter)
Yeah, and then, poof.
It was off to the heavens.
(sad piano music)
- Always remember to follow your dreams.
(long beep)
- Such beautiful last words.
(beeping)
- Grandpa?
He's alive.
Are you thirsty?
Grandpa?
- The black nurse drank my orange juice.
(long beep)
(crying)
- Actually, I'm a doctor.
- This isn't about you.
Grandpa.
- Yeah?
- He's dead.
- Boo.
(screaming)
- Whoa, man.
My mom tells me my comedy makes
people feel uncomfortable.
(laughter)
For the record, she also once told me
that Mount Rushmore occurred naturally.
(laughter)
When I was a kid I was diagnosed
with an auditory processing disorder.
The doctor explained it to me,
but I was like, what the
hell is he talking about?
(laughter)
I played violin when I was a kid.
One of the reasons I played violin
was there was this really cool, jocky dude
who was like, hey Pat,
hey Pat, you want to get
laid, you gotta play violin.
(laughter)
Looking back, I'm pretty
sure he said football.
Pretty sure I misprocessed a
crucial bit of information.
- You wanna get laid, nerd?
- Who's asking?
- I'm asking.
- Well then, no.
(grunting in pain)
Not bad for a little ballerina.
- I'm not a ballerina.
If you want to get laid, play the violin.
(classical orchestral music)
(violin music)
- Yo, Stephanie, I play violin now.
- Eew.
(music played in reverse)
- If you wanna get laid, play violin.
If you wanna get laid, play football.
(Asian string music)
(clearing throat)
- You wanna get laid, play violin.
(classical orchestral music)
No.
It was rough, you know, playing violin.
I got called a lot of names, guys,
names like Fiddle Bitch
and Dick Hands.
Some of the names were
unrelated to my violin playing.
The worst nickname I had, though,
was Vagina Dehumidifier.
(laughter)
Yeah, harsh.
I mean, coming from
your guidance counselor.
(laughter)
I was having sex with a 35 year old woman,
and she kept calling me Daddy.
I was like, what does she
call guys older than her?
My guess is brigadier general.
(laughter)
That's my guess, if I were to take one.
(moaning)
- Oh yeah, oh, oh, come on, grandpa.
Oh yeah, give me that wrinkled dick.
Oh, you're an ancient fossil.
Tell me about the war.
- Okay, well.
- Fuck me, you has-been.
- What?
- Can you do an old man voice for me?
(moaning)
Older.
(old man moaning)
Oh, weaker, weaker.
- Oh, is this what you want?
- Oh, put this on.
Oh, fuck me, George Washington.
Oh, you look like Christopher Lloyd.
- Ugh, what?
- Take me back to the future.
- All right.
- Break a hip in me.
Die on top of me, right here, right now.
(moaning)
- That was intense.
- Do you want some prune juice?
- Okay, what the fuck is going on here?
- I got some, I got some
movie ideas I'd like to pitch.
First movie idea is called
Speedboat Catastrophe.
It's a melodramatic tragedy about
a guy named Speedboat
battling Crohn's disease.
(laughter)
Movie idea number two
entitled Horse On The Freeway.
Everyone in L.A is late for work one day,
because there's a horse on the freeway,
and the whole movie is just
people honking their horns,
just screaming like, what the fuck.
Oh, shit, are you kidding me?
(screaming)
Should've never moved here, fuck.
And I'm gonna grab my guitar right now.
(applause)
(harmonica and acoustic guitar playing)
Hey, are they gonna pepper in more laughs?
(laughter)
When we edit, is there gonna be more?
God, man.
(harmonica and acoustic guitar playing)
♫ Sitting on my bedroom floor
♫ Feeling so alone
♫ Blackout all the windows
♫ And disconnect the phone
♫ No one calls me anyways
♫ No one even cares
♫ I could disappear like a ghost
♫ In a graveyard
♫ Open up the dresser drawer
♫ Where I keep my gun
♫ The cold black steel looks up at me
♫ Like shadows at the sun
♫ I load it up with bullets
♫ And I down a glass of rum
♫ It burns my throat but that's okay
♫ Because it numbs the pain
(laughter)
♫ Crying like a newborn child
♫ My hands they shake with fear
♫ I think it's what I have to do
♫ But I'm not thinking clear
♫ I close my eyes and count to three
♫ And draw one final breath
♫ Then I put the handgun in my mouth
♫ And guess what happens next
♫ I suck a gun like a dick
♫ I sucked a gun like a dick
♫ Gobble gobble gobble gobble
♫ Yum yum yum yum yum
♫ I want this .38 to shoot
a load across my tongue
♫ My troubles are forgotten
♫ Because I'm having so much fun
♫ Sucking this gun like a dick
(applause)
All right, thank you so
much, ladies and gentlemen.
Have a good night.
(cheers and applause)
(mellow indie music)